what's up guys bang bang this week was a
wild one in bitcoin let's get into these
bitcoin metrics brought to you by ftx us
obviously we've got uh bitcoin just
absolutely going sideways uh between a
pretty big range over the last uh
few weeks but we're coming up on a 10th
red weekly candle explain to people the
significance of uh these red candles on
the weekly uh charts
yeah i mean i
i just think it's kind of a fun fact
that we've reached a record number of
down candles and everyone keeps saying
well you know we've got the eighth in a
row certainly next week will be green
we've got the ninth in a row certainly
next week will be green and here we are
with this nasty wick on the top side of
the candle and
looks like we're
currently at least as we're speaking um
in the 10th red week in a row so pretty
pretty brutal price action and over the
last few months
all right and then if you start to look
at the importance of this is it just
something that traders look at or should
like regular bitcoin holders who are
just dollar cost averaging in or just
hold bitcoin to protect their economic
value
should they care about this idea of like
a 10-week losing streak like what's the
significance of 10 weekly red candles
i mean i just think it goes to show you
like how unprecedented the current price
action has been relative to bitcoin's
history uh and as we'll get to in a
moment you know i think this is a great
time to dcaa into bitcoin um we'll talk
in a moment that you know we haven't
reached full reset on a lot of these
on-chain oscillators as well as reach
some of these
technical levels things like the mayor
multiple or the 200 week moving average
but we are you know very close to those
and in the lower 10th or 25th percentile
of all these on-chain metrics i mean
which we've been saying for the last
month or two but it still holds true i
think for people who dollar cost average
into this asset this is the time where
you want to be ramping up your dca and
as i kind of put on twitter a little
while ago i think this is a dca or
paradise uh i think you know relative to
bitcoin's history
where bitcoin's trading based off of
just price action-oriented things or
also behavioral things shown by on-chain
i think we're at a great kind of area to
average into for the long-term investor
for sure
all right and then if we go ahead and we
take a look at these lower time frames
uh and bitcoin kind of being range bound
you've got a chart here uh that's
showing us um
what looks like it's just trading within
this band what what exactly are you
pulling from uh from this one
yeah i really honestly just put this
chart in here just to show like how
horrendous this price action has been
over the last like two or three weeks
we've just been in a range and it just
is grabbing liquidity on both sides of
it
so meaning like you know fake out to the
upside of the range fake out below the
bottom of the range it's just not the
type of trading that i find conducive in
this environment i think
you know in this environment you want to
be building
long-term positions and things that
you're convicted and obviously for me
that's that's bitcoin
but yeah really just
you know maybe if you have some type of
you know real material edge and order
flow or something like that on these
lower time frames then that's different
uh but you know i think even for people
that are just looking to play the range
that even really hasn't been that
conducive because you've just seen price
action faking out to both sides and
trapping traders looking to trade the
brake out of the range on both sides so
just pretty horrendous ugly choppy price
action
all right then you pointed out that the
nasdaq uh correlation with bitcoin on
the one day uh has finally decoupled uh
which i know says something that you've
been pointing out you know kind of how
high the correlation has been uh for a
while now why do you think this is
happening and what's the ramifications
yeah sure so i mean obviously like you
mentioned we've been in a really high
correlation to the nasdaq uh the three
day correlation last week hit an
all-time high
about a month or two ago the one week
correlation and all-time high i mean
however whatever time frame you want to
look at bitcoin's been
basketed by the broader market and with
uh just you know the nasdaq and tech
stocks and just broader risk assets so
it's been interesting over the last week
to see this decline uh we are still kind
of in this lower bound of
where the correlation has been trading
over the last few months
but it did get pretty low a few days ago
um and it's funny because
we've been talking about decoration
decoupling all the stuff right in and we
got the decoupling but it was in the
opposite direction of what we would have
liked to see which is pretty funny um
but i think what that kind of goes to
show you is just the simple fact that
like you had some unique flows coming
from btc maybe fund redemptions or
something like that but yeah
it was pretty brutal for those two days
uh you finally saw this decoupling but
it was stocks were rebounding and
bitcoin was kind of just like bleeding
down so
uh nonetheless though i do like to see
that we're kind of trading at this
uh lower level of correlation as arthur
hayes put in his uh his piece over the
last few days i think it was two days
ago he published it he was saying to him
this is kind of a bottoming signal
i think you could definitely make the
case for that but nonetheless i do like
to see btc trading on its own
got it and then if all of a sudden uh we
start looking at bitcoin dominance like
how do you think about uh
if the decoupling of the correlations uh
occurs then should we expect that to
mean dominance is going up or are these
two completely unrelated
look i think so
the way that historically the the crypto
market has worked is that
in bull markets well i should start with
with the bear because it kind of gives
you the base for the bowl so you know in
the in the bear market people put you
know put their money into things that
have real fundamental value they're not
just throwing money into you know i
don't know if i can curse on your dog
[ __ ] right you know throwing money into
shiba you knew and and dogecoin right
so in in the bear you get this
consolidation of liquidity into majors
uh primarily like btc and ethan 2018
and that allows you to kind of get this
move into the into the bull run when you
have properly allocated capital and then
as you head into that kind of area of
exuberance in the bowl then you see the
liquidity disperse into other assets uh
you know obviously in 2021 the kind of
uh darling you know whatever crypto
hedge fund trade was you know the the
solenoid avax all one trade uh and so
what happens is you have all these new
projects coming in into the space in a
bull market uh you get all this new
talent that comes into the space
building things and what happens
eventually is that the amount of new
products that come into this space or
projects outpaces the amount of capital
inflows that are able to support all
that dispersion
and then those capital influence just
can't hold up the market and then you
get that liquidity flow back to btc and
i should say majors uh but in
specifically btc
and then that kind of starts the the
cycle all over again so in 2018 we had
this pretty clean kind of double bottom
uh in
kind of the mid to latter half of 2018
uh now it looks like we're shaping some
type of rounded bottom in btc dominance
and it's now 19 off the lows so
uh now bitcoin makes up about 47 of the
total crypto market cash
and then when we look as this is playing
out we've got the etfs continue to get
inflows uh you've included the canadian
purpose bitcoin spot etf uh is this just
like price goes down and a certain
subset of investors find that attractive
they are going to buy bitcoin now
they're more excited because it's
cheaper than it was uh and that's why
the etfs are getting the inflows even
though the price is going down because
someone somewhere is selling so like
etf's more service like a retail
exposure
i mean look i don't know
you know who is buying through the
purpose etf and like what their
intentions are i mean in theory it would
likely be the fact that the price has
been declining so people find an
advantageous time to buy in
but nonetheless like we have seen and
you know that's all opinionated but as
to the facts are that the canadian
purpose uh bitcoin spot etf has seen an
inflow of about 11 350 btc in the last
30 days which has been the most
aggressive 30-day increase in its
existence which is pretty interesting to
me i mean 11 000 btc isn't going to
bottom the market out or anything i just
do find it interesting that we've got
you know the the largest uh spot etf for
btc and that's seen continuous uh
inflows despite the downtrend over the
last month or two
all right and then if we take a look at
the on-chain cost basis what we're
seeing here is uh again bitcoin
continues to fall closer and closer to
that on-chain cost basis uh is your
expectation that we're going to hit it
at some point um or how do you look at
the relationship between price and uh
this cost basis
sure so this is kind of what we were
talking about at the beginning um and
also i should reference last week's show
not to just tell people to keep
listening to me rambling but
i think you know last week we talked
about
a lot of these different metrics that
we'd be looking at to kind of identify
like a cyclical bottom and so
because of that i only included two in
this week's but these are the two kind
of most relevant to me personally
uh i think the broader theme as we kind
of talk about the beginning
is that all of these metrics are in the
lower kind of 10th percentile of you
know in historical trading values now
they aren't at a full reset which we'll
get to in a second and that's where i'm
personally looking to allocate because
you know maybe you could say i'm a
little greedy and and you know i want to
try to somewhat time the bottom
um or at least the range where bitcoin
is historically bottomed off of these
metrics but you know i think for for the
average person who's just looking to you
know dollar cost average in the btc i
mean this is where you really want to
ramp that up heavily and start throwing
larger allocations into that to that dc
dca that you're doing every day or every
week or however often that's
that you're doing that um to look at
this chart in specific so this is
looking at the short term holder
realized price
or cost basis of short-term holders
and the long-term holder realized price
or cost basis of long-term holders so in
the kind of uh pink or red line that's
the short-term holder realized price in
the light blue that's the long-term
holder realized price
what you'll note is that heading into
the bear market well you'll note a few
things first of all uh the short-term
holder cost basis is a really important
price level we've talked about for a
long time on this show it serves as
support in the bull market as well as
resistance in the bear uh there's some
pretty deep psychological ramifications
as to why that happens in my opinion uh
in the bull run people don't want to
sell at a loss that have just come into
the market because the market's just
running up over a multi-month period so
that's why you see some selling subside
whenever we retest that cost basis
heading back into the bear you get these
failed underside re-tests because people
just want to look to break even as
bitcoins going down 40 50 and they don't
have any type of long-term conviction
whenever that short-term holder cost
basis crosses below the long-term holder
cost basis that's marked really good as
i put in the newsletter generational buy
opportunity for btc so essentially you
have capitulation from the short-term
holders slash short-term holders aging
into long-term holders um but that
the indicator is showing you that the
short-term holder realized price crosses
below that long-term holding realized
price and that's that that's kind of
that that buy zone and then if you want
to get a bit more granular you could
even just wait for the confirmation of
the cross back above so what i'd be
looking to do
is buy once the short term holder
realized price crosses below the long
term holder and that would put it below
that green line at the bottom so that
simply means that the short term holder
cost basis has gone below the long term
holder but you could also just wait for
the confirmation of that coming back out
of that buy zone and and that's kind of
a momentum confirmation if you will of
us coming out at the bottom uh so those
are two approaches that you could take
but the one i'm looking to do is just
averaging heavily if if that short-term
holder realized price did go above the
long-term holder got it and then if we
take a look at uh the mv rv z score and
uh we also look at things like number of
active addresses what's interesting to
me is the envy rv z score uh continues
to fall closer and closer to that like
green buy zone that we've been talking
about and kind of a continuation of the
trend but what we have seen that's
changed that isn't a continuation of the
trend uh is the number of active
addresses on this 14 day moving average
uh we've seen that drop
do you look at um
you know kind of directionally if
everything was just continuing the trend
we had eight nine ten weeks of uh red
candles like you'd be okay that's what
you would expect as price goes down all
of the trends continue through kind of
this
market correction how do you think of it
when you see some continuations of trend
like mvrv z score uh but also some
diversion from past trends like active
addresses are actually dropping instead
of uh increasing
yeah it's interesting the way i look at
like active addresses is essentially
like a proxy for kind of
the amount of you know as as in the
definition the amount of activity on on
the network uh so that's been in a
decline since november of last year and
never got close to the levels reached uh
in may of of last year as well actually
the the kind of peak for number of
active addresses ironically was on may
19th which was the day before we went
down uh 30 which is like kind of the
you know peak of visual of of when the
herd is going one way go the opposite
way um but yeah i mean this is kind of
what you expect in the bear market you
see a lack of exuberance you see
everything kind of cool down
a lot of the quote unquote you know
visitors or or
people vacationing into the btc market
believe and disperse as it's not going
up only anymore and you get left with
only the hardcore uh convicted believers
you get a capital transfer back to those
market participants and that
concentration of the capital back to
those market participants allows for the
next drastic run-up
in the same way that when those market
participants that were buying at the
bottom dispersed back to all the ones
with low conviction at the top that
allows for such a large correction it
goes both ways um and so i think this is
just one of those indicators of that
kind of cool off in exuberance now to
get to uh the mvrv z score as i said
this was in combination with the
on-chain cost basis you could also throw
the 200-week moving average in here as
well uh this is a more
these are these are the more relevant
metrics that i'm looking at um to
allocate the rest of the dry powder that
i'm that i'm sitting on currently
uh so this compares the market cap i'm
inside the the market value in this case
we're looking at price and not market
cap so it's the the market price to the
realized price uh realized price being
just the aggregated uh average cost
basis of all the entities on chain based
on the last time that coins removed um
as you can see that that red zone kind
of uh signals euphoria or over
exuberance in the market
we did tap it but we didn't get that
kind of blow off push through that we
were kind of expecting that historically
has taken place but nonetheless we did
hit that overheated zone
and and that bottom zone this green zone
is an indicator that the market uh price
has dropped below the realized price
which currently sits at about 24 000. uh
so if you get market price going below
that realized price then we will enter
that green zone at the bottom and that
green zone at the bottom has
historically marked kind of generational
buy opportunities for btc so you know on
one hand you could you probably have
some people that say well we barely got
into that you know zone of exuberance at
the top kind of got that rounded top and
we're very close to that uh
that bottoming area getting below that
realized price maybe it's close enough
for you to want to dca into that that's
you know your personal decision but we
are very close
or you could be in the camp of waiting
for that full reset into that green zone
which has historically been kind of a
no-brainer buy opportunity
got it and then what about geographic
premiums like i know you said that asia
was putting a premium in the last couple
of weeks is that still continuing
for sure so this is looking at the
trading hours uh broken down between
asian united states uh and europe and so
this compares asian to the other two
uh and so what you see is like based on
this at least asia has kind of dominated
the market over the last uh two years or
so
you saw them by the bottom after the
covid crash
and sell right before the coveted crash
they sold all the way down into the top
in the beginning of 2021. they bought
essentially they bought the puke from us
and in europe at the bottom uh in the
middle of summer of last year and then
dumped back on them uh on the pump off
the lows
uh they bought that re-test of 40k and
then sold aggressively in november
the most of which they ever have um and
it's kind of the end of november into
december
bought back in january at that kind of
local bottom that we set
sold into the top of the range and then
recently they've been buying again
according to the to the trading hour
premium uh and this is the most
aggressive increase in the in the
premium that we've seen since summer of
last year so that's super interesting
another thing is i watched the order
books uh a fair amount and not like you
know 24 7. um but that is something like
every few hours i'll go in and just
check kind of what's going on and like
myself and a few other traders that i
speak with and whatever group chats and
things like that i've noticed there's
been this kind of persistent bidder in
binances order book which is of course
an asian-based exchange so kind of
seeing confluence in the order books as
well with with what i'm seeing in the in
the trading hour premium
got it and then blake help us understand
in terms of the macro environment like
what are you seeing uh that you think is
uh is relevant here to uh to bitcoin
um yeah so i mean i i kind of think
the name of the game right now is that
we're in this rising interest rate
environment um and you know the effect
of this is mostly uh initially into the
bond market so
interest rates and bond prices have this
inverse relationship and you know
uh bitcoin guys normally don't like to
hear about you know bond markets you
know they're boring or whatever but i
think they're super important from an
institutional perspective
so essentially
you know interest rates are rising so
bond prices are falling which makes
yields rise and you know institutions
use bond yields to evaluate stocks
it kind of helps them form their risk
preferences
so when you have these rising yields
bond or stock valuations fall
um which makes you know kind of scares
institutions so they're they go they go
towards risk off so that's why you see
you know all these tech stocks are are
falling you know we're in a bear market
in tech stocks and that bleeds over into
uh the crypto atmosphere uh into the
bitcoin market so i think just that
whole you know rising interest rate
environment is um super important for um
you know bitcoin investors and stock
investors as well to understand
yeah it it it's really interesting to
kind of see as well was talking about
like the correlations and and uh to
stock as well um
and to understand that probably a lot of
people who are speculating on bitcoin uh
from the wall street world that would
have this as the riskiest asset in their
portfolio they've likely dumped it at
this point and so it could be a big sign
as to why we're getting the bifurcation
of correlations et cetera is that kind
of how you see it as well
yeah i think so i you know like i said i
think it all comes down to risk
preferences so when you start to go risk
off um you know these institutions like
in the funds hedge funds mutual funds
they treat bitcoin like a risk asset
right they treat it like a tech stock um
they don't necessarily treat it for you
know the network effect that you know we
as you know bitcoiners believe in um so
i think that's kind of the name of the
game is just that when the fed is you
know uh trying to slow down the economy
they you know scares institutions and
they want to get out of their bitcoin
yeah it's um
it's crazy how simplistic uh it can be
at times right of like just supply
demand fear etc um when you start
thinking about the quantitative
tightening that's occurring what's your
expectation of how bitcoin gets treated
here is it just correlations go towards
one and all macro uh is the overwhelming
force and assets you know underlying
fundamentals don't matter or something
different
um yeah so i think it's kind of it's
kind of hard to say so you know the last
quantitative tightening cycle we saw was
2018 2019 and it was almost you know
really disastrous for the markets so the
fed kind of overshot their qt goal um
and they almost you know crashed the
economy so um i think you know and today
their plan is to be even more aggressive
than they were back then um yeah so
there you're looking at the last qt
cycle 2018 2019 and you know generally
in quantitative tightening right they're
shrinking their balance sheet so they're
drawing liquidity out of the markets so
what should happen is that the economy
slows down and prices fall but there if
you look at the blue line like cpi which
you know is arguably not a great
indicator of inflation but it's most
widely used by institutions um you know
cpi was rising during that environment
so you know they overshot their goal and
created you know a bunch of issues the s
p was very close to a bear market it's
down like 19 uh before they you know
reverse course and kind of saves uh
stocks and bonds um and you know today
they're planning to be even more
aggressive so i think we'll probably see
you know open market selling of their
bonds so
generally in qt you're either selling
your bonds or you're allowing them to
mature so
you know if people don't understand
bonds so you you buy them for a fixed
amount of time right so you've heard of
the 10 year or the two year or whatever
so at that at the end of the 10 years
your bond matures and you receive the
principal so with the treasury bond you
save a thousand dollars um so now in a
qe environment which is what we had for
the last two years the fed will take
that principle and go buy more bonds but
now in qt they're just taking that
principle um not buying more bonds so
they're shrinking their balance sheet um
and then we're also probably going to
see them open market selling bonds um so
whether this causes you know a big spike
in yields i think um kind of depends on
the liquidity of the bond market and
just you know how aggressive they
actually end up selling their bonds um
so i think it's kind of up in the air
and how this actually ends up playing
out
yeah
what's your thought process on their
ability to continue to cut rates uh
through the end of the year like will
they have to or i'm sorry increase rates
at the end of the year will they
basically have to continue to increase
and just push us further and further
into a recessionary period and not worry
about asset prices or do you think that
uh at some point no they're actually
going to have to uh
um you know maybe cool off pause maybe
even reverse course like how do you see
this playing out
yeah so i think um i mean you know the
fed or in powell has said repeatedly you
know their focus is inflation they're
not as much worried about the stock
market which is kind of a reverse or a
change in uh behavior historically um
but you know they're also saying we're
gonna do anything we can to slow
inflation and then two minutes later
they say you know a 70 basis point hike
is off the table you know which is just
classic um you know fed maneuvering um
but i think kind of the issue that we
have is that you know we're in this you
know fiat system so since 1971 nixon
severs ties to the gold standard so now
it um you know you have this currency
where there's nothing you know in
reality backing it right there's before
you have you could only have so many
dollars because each dollar is worth x
amount of gold and you can't have more
dollars and you have gold but now under
this fiat system the government is
allowed to print as much currency as
they want right and that's what they do
they you know they just print currency
to solve their problems um but the issue
is you know you inflate um you know the
amount of currency out there and it
decreases purchasing power so what it
does is it decentivizes saving in usd
right the analogy a lot of people use is
like it's like holding your money in you
know a melting ice cube of purchasing
power so what that does is it
incentivizes people to go and borrow
money right you take on debt and if you
look at you know total outstanding
public debt levels um you know it
basically just goes up and to the right
um
so what happens is you know people build
more and more debt um and then the fed
you know maybe they need to raise
interest rates to help slow the economy
bring down prices
but the issue is you know there's so
much debt out there that people you know
stop um being able to you know repay
their debt right they become insolvent
um and here you can see you know that's
you know u.s public debt as a percentage
of gdp so basically looking at how much
debt is there in comparison to economic
output and what you see now is you know
it
public debt to gdp is at an all-time
high right it's even higher than the
inflationary period of the 1940s where
the government is paying for the second
world war so we just see massive amounts
of debt in the system so over time
interest rates you know are falling it
makes it even more attractive uh to take
on debt um and the issue is so the fed
starts to raise interest rates and
people are like well well we can't
afford this cause this recession you
know people are defaulting on debt um
and the fed has to you know reverse
course and bring interest rates back
lower so this kind of repeats over and
over and it creates these short term
debt cycles which are you know commonly
referred to as like the business cycle
three to seven year uh business cycle
but then eventually you reach this lower
limit so you either have to you know
increase interest rates to save the
economy or i'm sorry to slow the economy
um then you know people are you know
insolvent so you have to bring interest
rates back down but then you reach its
lower limit where you're essentially
stuck between zero and the level where
it causes uh insolvency and that's kind
of where we're at now so the fed has
said you know we're going to raise
interest rates at 50 basis points for
each you know hike or each fmoc meeting
which is five left in the year so this
would put the fed funds rate at you know
three to three and a half percent uh by
the end of the year and the issue is you
know if you look at um the trend of the
fed funds rate over time
you know once you kind of reach this
downtrend uh this you know channel once
you reach the top of it it creates this
insolvency and it causes a recession so
now the fed's kind of stuck between this
rock and a hard place where they either
need to raise interest rates to bring
down the prices of goods or they raise
interest rates and you know people
default in their debt and causes a
recession
if i could just hop in real quick
getting that chart up with the uh with
the downtrend of the fed funds would be
really helpful to kind of illustrate
what he's saying just for just for
listener's sake do you all have that one
we do we'll pull it up here
when you look at the fed's fundraising
uh as it's kind of falling here
there we go i mean just off a cliff
right just continuous down persistent
only
right so you can see um it's kind of
hard to see on my screen i think you can
see like the um
gray vertical channels that those
indicate uh recessionary periods yep
so what you see is every time the fed
funds rate so the fed funds rate is that
blue line with the red downtrend line
drawn across the top what you see is
every time the fed funds rate reaches
that downtrend line it's essentially you
know interest payments are too high for
people to afford um and they are
insolvent on their debt and it causes
this recession so if the fed is really
going to bring interest rates to three
to three and a half percent um you know
you're going to be way above that
downtrend line you're going to be even
higher you know than that last high you
know that 2018 2019 peak you can see
there we'd be above that um so it would
just create these issues so
what i think um and what a lot of people
think is that the fed is you know jaw
boning so they're essentially um you
know the markets are forward-looking
right so if the fed's saying yeah you're
gonna have a three percent fed funds
rate the market isn't going to wait
until that actually comes to you know
take action on that the market's just
gonna immediately start pricing that
information in so what i think the fed
is doing is they're saying you know
you're gonna get a three percent fed
funds rate so that it gets priced in and
then they don't actually have to do it
when the time comes
yeah i mean my
base case here is that they obviously
don't get the 10 interest rate hikes we
don't get a 300 basis point interest uh
by the end of the uh by the end of the
year but i still am holding out i think
that there's a chance
i'm not saying that for sure it's gonna
happen but i do think that there's a
chance we get an interest rate cut
before the end of the year as like a way
to basically instill some confidence
back into the market because they you
know continue to hike rates there's even
just more sell-off more sophomore
sell-off at some point they say oh we
went too far let's just give kind of a a
little check here into the market um
which you know it wouldn't be the first
time they've done that but still uh i
don't think people think that's going to
happen at this point
right no i agree i i guess we'll see i
mean it's kind of anyone's guess at this
point
what's the important thing i think like
one thing that's perhaps maybe a bit
different than like 2018 for example is
you you started to see the fed talking
about their credibility
right and i think that's like really
interesting now i think they're almost
on like this
uh darius said this on the podcast that
he was recently on with you they're
almost on this tear to like redeem
themselves after they admitted that they
made a huge policy mistake over the last
two years i think i think that's just
like one interesting thing to keep in
mind that perhaps they're going to just
keep pushing this until it breaks um
because they're they're essentially like
trying to reclaim their their
credibility in kind of crushing
inflation so and you've also seen like
powell start like comparing himself to
volcker which has been pretty
interesting right because obviously like
volcker raised interest rates like 18
uh which was insane causing like
recessions but i mean he did he did
crush inflation but i i do think like
from like a just human standpoint of
like you know credibility step with the
fact that they're talking about they
want to you know basically do this to
like reclaim their their credibility as
an entity i think is like just one
interesting thing i guess to keep in
mind but sorry to sorry to hop in and
cut you off
let me ask one last question to let you
guys go blake when you think about um
kind of bitcoin market and macro and the
intersection what's the one thing is it
just the fed that's the thing to watch
for the rest of the year or are there
other things that you're paying
attention to
um i think i mean i pay attention a lot
of attention to the fed because you know
like i was talking about earlier that
you know spills over directly into the
bond market and then that's kind of the
institutional you know risk preference
you know decision making is based off
you know the bond market and bond yields
um so i kind of think that's the area to
watch and i kind of harp about that in
the newsletter and on twitter and
whatnot that you know people need to be
watching yields um and you know and as
boring as it is and the bond market
isn't as fun as you know the bitcoin
market um it's really important because
you know institutions are generally what
drive you know stocks to go on massive
runs or you know other types of assets
to go on you know big sustainable runs
so it's really important to you know
keep an eye on institutions right
there's this quote you know um you know
when you see you know stock breaking out
on big volume right that isn't your aunt
sally buying right that's a
mutual fund putting a billion dollars
into a stock or whatever so it's really
important i think um if you're someone
who you know wants to see bitcoin to see
succeed you want to watch what the
institutions are doing so i think you
know what the fed's doing and what the
bond market's doing in bond yields is
really important to keep an eye on
yeah it's um
it's gonna be a wild wild freaking
couple of months but uh i appreciate you
guys both coming on where can we send
people to find you guys on the internet
uh you can follow me on twitter um
blakedavis50
that's me there he is
you got a new profile picture
fresh
i took that in my uh backyard selfie
timer
there you go
i love it i love it and then will oh
yeah 636 now
we're trying to we're trying to pump up
we're trying to pump up blake's numbers
i would i would also say um
i'd also say uh check out the newsletter
of course no link is link is in the bio
free
if you liked anything of of the two of
us uh rambling today would would uh you
know love to have some some new people
checking out the newsletter get some
feedback on it where where do we send
them what's the url
oh we just changed it i think it's uh
sign up both of our
newsletter.intelligence.com
or it's yeah in both of our bios
and we just also one other thing for uh
people who are spanish-speaking we also
just integrated uh you can now subscribe
to a spanish version of the newsletter
if you go to our website and on the in
the link in my bio
you can also subscribe to that if you're
interested in that
all right fellas i appreciate both you
guys coming on uh i learned something
every single week with will and blake
will have to have to bring you back as
well uh as all this uh continues to uh
to play out but i appreciate it and uh
we'll have you guys back soon
thank you for having me thanks so much
pom have a great weekend man all right
later fellas hey you did you like this
video great we make five of them a day
and post them here on this channel make
sure you subscribe like the video and
see you next time